[Musique]
beau matin soeur Dina frère
soeur Fernanda soeur Alessandra soeur
Mariana est tes péchés
bling-bling chienne fais mon propre truc [ __ ]
conversation sale ta propre [ __ ] d'
affaire la
luxure tes yeux savent que tu
roules des yeux
réveillez-vous lait chiennes laissez-moi vous montrer
comment vivre avez-vous entendu ce que les filles peuvent être
dures Je ne vais pas mentir elles peuvent être très
dures avec une autre femme parfois
elle jouait le sexe juste quand quelqu'un
pénétrait l'arrière c'est aussi quelque chose
que tu as fait que j'ai fait
[Musique]
morceau  de la langue révolution du kérosène
manger du sang pensez-vous que j'ai déjà
écrit un manger du sang avant
où suis-je bling bling [ __ ] faire mon propre
truc boucle de [ __ ] bague de mariage cette [ __ ] qui
ding-a-ling
vous